bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check up votre magazine santé
bien-être au sommaire de ce nouveau
numéro du rire et de l'humour dans les
hôpitaux une action de solidarité
proposée par une association yvelinoise
nous découvrirons également une thérapie
qui vient en aide au malade du cancer la
proximologie mais tout d'abord le
premier sujet depuis 17 ans
l'association Mécénat chirurgicardiaque
permet aux enfants défavoriser malades
du cœur de venir se faire opérer en
France lors de leur séjour de deux mois
environ juste après leur opération ils
sont suivis dans un centre pédiatrique
yvelinois nous les avons suivis Jonathan
Wilman pour les images
Dany est arrivé en France il y a un peu
plus d'un mois il y a quelques jours
cette petite burundes de 2 ans s'est
fait opérer d'une malformation cardiaque
et pour vérifier que tout va bien elle
se rend toutes les semaines ici au
centre pédiatrique des côtes au loge
Jean-Joseph sa famille d'accueil
bénévole connaît déjà ses petits traits
de caractère elle aime bien être dans
les bras mais de moins en moins de moins
en moins maintenant elle joue toute
seule elle joue toute seule vous voyez
elle passe des heures
à nous poser les questions et hier il
fallait suivre il fallait
avec son petit doigt elle faisait comme
ça
l'accueil des enfants est rendu possible
grâce à l'association Messenger
cardiaque une fois que les enfants ont
été opérés dans les hôpitaux partenaires
il séjourne ici entre trois jours et une
semaine pour la suite de la prise en
charge post-opératoire pendant cette
période notre centre assure donc une
surveillance médicale et paramédicale
avec notamment la réalisation
d'échographie cardiaque
d'électrocardiogramme
pour s'assurer qu'il n'y a pas de
complications post-opératoire
immédiate justement
lui vient de se faire opérer et gardent
encore quelques pansements sur lui sa
maladie pouvait conduire à une
insuffisance cardiaque aujourd'hui il
espère pouvoir chausser les crampons dès
son retour chez lui au Congo
j'y suis content parce que mes amis
jouer les ballons moi je veux pas de
ballon maintenant au moins opérer on dit
que après je vais commencer à jouer le
ballon c'est ça c'est là que je suis
content oui je vais être invoque pour
aller
chaque année comme lui et Dany environ
200 enfants de pays défavorisés viennent
se faire opérer du coeur en France alors
pourquoi ils peuvent pas être soignés
sur place parce que
manque d'argent
manque de technicité
manque de spécialiste car la chirurgie
cardiaque de l'enfant c'est quand même
une spécialité dans la spécialité pour
donner un coup de pouce à l'association
chaque année un tournoi de golf
solidaire est organisé à ça dans la
Bretèche pour cette 17ème édition du
Trophée du coeur Dany Boon a accepté
d'en être le parrain c'est une histoire
de coup de cœur et après de dire et
d'espèces après je voilà après il faut
c'est là disponible pour
pour aider l'association et mettre ma
notoriété au service de la récolte de
fond quoi
lors de ce trophée du coeur les fonds
récoltés vont permettre de sauver 11
enfants pour la prise en charge de
chaque malade mais c'est là chirurgie
cardiaque a besoin de 12000 € en moyenne
une somme qui serait deux à trois fois
plus élevé sans l'association et ses
familles d'accueil bénévoles engagés
depuis plusieurs années Josiane est déjà
le cinquième enfant que Cécile reçoit
chez elle et à chaque fois le même
bonheur on s'ouvre déjà simplement
l'ouverture à une culture à des pays et
un plus petit qui en a vraiment besoin
qui est condamné si reste chez lui donc
on sent franchement on sent utile
retour au centre des côtes avec Dany
dans quelques semaines elle repartira
chez elle au Burundi la bas son médecin
référent formé par l'association
continuera à la suivre sur place quand
ils partent bon c'est tout après on
passe aux petits enfants qui vont venir
en vacances voilà chaque chose voilà ma
chérie
en 17 ans l'association a déjà permis à
plus de 2200 enfants de se faire opérer
du cœur
rire pour guérir c'est le nom de
l'action proposé par l'association rire
78 une vingtaine d'artistes se
produisent dans les hôpitaux du
département pour y apporter leur joie et
leur bonne humeur il y a quelques jours
nous avons rencontré le ventriloque
Christian Gabriel et son singe Freddy
ils sont venus à la rencontre des
enfants malades de l'hôpital Mignot du
Chesnay Patrick Jacques de dixmuck pour
les images
sans l'autre Christian Gabriel et son
singe Freddy se sont arrêtés il y a
quelques jours à l'hôpital Mignot du
Chesnay
grand ventriloque reconnu Christian
Gabriel fait partie des artistes engagés
dans l'association rire 78 créer il y a
7 ans à travers son spectacle les
enfants s'évadent un moment de leur
chambre d'hôpital
dans le service ça nous change les idées
un peu
et d'après les médecins l'humour aurait
de réel bienfaits sur la santé ah je
pense que quand on est en face de
maladie chronique ou quand on est
vraiment hospitalisé le fait de rire de
pouvoir se détendre ça peut être ça peut
aider l'enfant à penser à autre chose et
pourquoi pas à mieux guérir c'est
possible
que je suis baigné
habitué des grands musicaux et des
cabarets parisiens le duo attache
toujours une importance particulière à
ce produire devant ses enfants malades
j'ai pas mal passé dedans de temps dans
les hôpitaux voilà donc les enfants j'ai
vu un petit peu la détresse des enfants
le côté un petit peu il reste tout seul
donc voilà les amuser avec Freddy et
voilà c'est pour rendre hommage aussi un
artiste un grand artiste qui nous a
quitté qui s'appelle Bernard Giraudeau
qui t'a donné les amis et puis
malheureusement quand il était à
l'hôpital on allait voir les enfants et
tout ça et puis je continue je le
faisais avant de connaître je continue à
le faire et on le fera toujours quoi
le duo ne s'arrête pas là il sera au
centre clinique de psychothérapie à
Poissy le 16 mai prochain
les soins ontologiques de support une
thérapie assez méconnue en France il
s'agit d'un accompagnement psychologique
et corporel pour les malades du cancer
et leurs proches nous avons rencontré un
spécialiste ivinois et leur passion pour
en savoir plus Jonathan villeman pour
les images
régulièrement pierre reçoit son
thérapeute chez lui au Chesnay comment
allez-vous aujourd'hui
retraitée continue à travailler jusqu'à
son opération pour surmonter cette
épreuve il ressent le besoin de parler
d'échanger d'être rassuré son médecin
l'oriente alors verset thérapeute expert
en soins écologique de support
s quand j'étais trop stressé et trop
tendu
et voilà et ça m'a fait du bien vous
savez les psychologique je pense qu'elle
est nécessaire quand même parce que
quand ça vous arrive on abolir on a beau
prendre sur soi s'afficher un coup
Louis XV le thérapeute se rend à
domicile mais reçoit aussi certains
patients dans son cabinet à Paris dans 4
mois il a ménagera ses nouveaux locaux
chez lui au Chesnay dans les Yvelines et
plus généralement en France son métier
est assez peu répandu on parle de
proximologie le thérapeute vient en
complément des soins médicaux de
l'oncologue avec qui il est en contact
direct le but c'est de donner confiance
à mon patient et qui se sentent mieux
donc ça va être par l'échange comme je
disais et par les postures se sentir
bien dans son corps même si on sent son
corps affaibli ou en douleur le but
c'est d'optimiser et de donner confiance
aux patients et surtout de vivre avec sa
maladie le plus important c'est de vivre
ça c'est très important et les patients
à partir du moment on annonce une
maladie lourde pour eux c'est la mort à
assurer ce qui est pas vrai du tout
les séances se sont personnalisées en
fonction des besoins et de l'état
physique du patient mais en moyenne il
faut compter une à deux séances par
semaine il s'agit d'un accompagnement
psychologique mais pas seulement
j'estime que le corporel a une son
importance donc une séance va durer à
peu près une heure ça peut durer à peu
près 20-25 minutes un quart d'heure
l'échange et après il va avoir une
séance de masse au thérapie où je vais
appuyer sur les points de tension où je
vais dénouer etc ou une réflexologie
tout dépend le ressenti que j'ai et les
attentes du patient la séance se conclut
généralement par un nouvel échange
parmi ces patients il compte aussi les
proches des malades Nathalie par exemple
a senti le besoin d'être accompagné
lorsque son mari a appris son cancer on
a pu discuter changer
peut-être aussi les charges un peu les
angoisses qu'on avait donc c'est vrai
que ça ça m'a beaucoup aidé aussi parce
que c'est vrai que pour le malade c'est
compliqué mais c'est vrai que souvent la
personne qui est là et qui est qui est à
côté et qui est aussi enfin concerné
c'est parfois difficile le problème
c'est que ce sont de support restent
encore un luxe il faut compter entre 50
et 100 euros la séance et aucun
remboursement n'est prévu d'après le
thérapeute même si ses soins commencent
à se développait depuis deux ou trois
ans cela reste encore insuffisant pas du
matériel cher ça demande de l'humain
avec des connaissances sur l'oncologie
pour adapter des soins par rapport à des
pathologies et bah faut former les gens
et il faut rémunérer les gens
pour le moment les proximologues
exercent grâce aux bouches à oreilles
mais aussi grâce aux praticiens et
jeunes oncologues qui les recommandent
d'après le thérapeute aujourd'hui 60%
des personnes atteintes du cancer ont
déjà eu recours à des soins de support
en complément de leur traitement
principal
c'est la fin de ce nouveau numéro avant
de nous quitter jetons un coup d'œil sur
les Data à retenir le samedi 24 mai le
musée de Port-Royal Deschamps vous
propose une journée consacrée au rapport
entre la santé le savoir-humain et les
plantes rendez-vous dès 10h à
Magny-les-Hameaux le mardi 3 juin le
docteur Jacques Segal vous propose un
nouveau goûter santé il vous donnera
quelques bons conseils pour être en
forme cet été ce sera de 14h à 16h au
centre socioculturel de merisiers à
Trappes check-up c'est terminé merci de
votre attention je vous donne
rendez-vous dans un mois d'ici là
portez-vous bien